now the London marathon is on Sunday
with tens of thousands of Runners taking
their marks now amongst them is the
autistic athlete Sam holner it's not
just a marathon runner but also an Iron
Man and triathlete and Sam and his
father and coach Tony join me now
welcome to both of you
um Sam first of all tell me a little bit
about how you started doing Iron Man and
Triathlon events
like ah I started we're doing a drive
from 2016.
and I've already completed a 5 30.3 army
races such as casca Holcomb Savage
and two full albums first First
Frankfurt Germany and secondly Kona
Hawaii wow that's quite a lot of
experience and what does the training
involve
oh oh the Chinese food a lot of hard
work
you know it's like a full-time job yeah
I know I know me would work six days
about six days per week
with one recovery day
on hard days I suppose could be a five
cases where that's 200 guys the 25
milligram pool
and
a five hour cycle or in a row on Swift
and uh of Freddie K who run on a
treadmill on a 20 AK indoora
wow that sounds I'm exhausted listening
to you and you've received a huge number
of Walls you've got one around your your
neck now the most recent is you've gone
into the Guinness book of records as the
first autistic person to complete the
Iron Man World Championship Triathlon so
what did that mean to you
oh it means oh I didn't expect to
receive for goodness the world record it
was so exciting I it was and you're Keen
to encourage other people with Autism to
take part in uh triathlons and other
sporting events so what are the
challenges that people with Autism might
face when they take on this kind of
thing
oh
oh there are
what's up oh it's the challenge oh oh
there's so many challenges before doing
a tri afron
first thing is the only to swim I
couldn't swim before I started speaking
uh at six years old
I could swim so I didn't want to ride a
bike until I was 14 because Burns in the
bank was difficult
how effective I think like people with
autistic can't do well I suppose because
many of us can focus for your periods
without being distracted yes of course
and Tony I want to bring you in here
you've been very keen to encourage Sam
to do Sports what difference do you
think it's made it's been enormous I
think it's been life-changing for him
and for us as a family
um I think we started sport when
we found some research that said the
life expectancy in the UK of adults with
autism is under 54 years
and that's because of health reasons and
diet and so on so we decided that sport
had to be one of the ways to actually
help him to eat healthier and be
healthier and triathlins one as he
started off as a sort of bucket list and
it's just exploded into this wonderful
thing that he enjoys so great for his
physical health but what about managing
the autism does that make a difference
yeah I I think um so Sam as he said he
didn't speak till he was six years old
and he was swimming before he could and
I think it's the confidence that you get
from sport is help with his
communication skills it's allowed him to
talk it's allowed to be a lot more fluid
to stand in front of people I mean three
or four years ago he couldn't have sat
this studio like this and had this
discussion and fantastic for anyone
watching in a similar situation a real
inspiration yeah I think um for all of
us I get up every morning and I look and
I see DMS from parents around the world
and I'm talking from South Africa Canada
everywhere saying we follow Sam simply
because he gives us hope for our
children and that's how my day starts
every day and the London marathon on
Sunday of course you'll be there
cheering them on I assume I tell you
what I will be every stride he takes
I'll be running with him and following
him on the app
but I think this one's a bit easier for
us because when he does a Iron Man for
example
um and we're in Hawaii he swam 3.8
kilometers out in the sea and then he
cycle 180 kilometers and we didn't see
him it's for over six hours that is
scary